we seem to have a problem with our main
engine it was the first sign all was not
well the faces of the team said it all
Israel's dream of landing on the moon
dissolving into bitter disappointment we
had a failure in the spacecraft we
unfortunately have not managed to land
successfully we are the seventh country
to orbit the moon and the fourth to
reach the moon's surface and it's a
tremendous achievement
up to now well we didn't make it but we
definitely tried a spacecraft selfie
taken minutes earlier promised so much
but an engine fault caused it to crash
scattering into thousands of pieces the
mission had hoped to inspire people from
across Israel its leader said it still
could if at first you don't succeed you
try again animations released before the
mission chart it's unusual path instead
of rocketing straight up Bereshit first
looped the earth before tipping into the
moon's orbit an engine was meant to slow
its descent but it unexpectedly turned
off by the time it refires
it was too late this has been the most
nail-biting perilous landing on the moon
there's ever been because this does have
much fuel on the spacecraft it can't
slow itself down gradually so what it
did was it actually headed on a crash
course to the sea of serenity
it was set to make history as the first
privately funded mission to the moon it
would have made Israel only the fourth
country to land on the lunar surface and
at less than 80 million pounds it
promised a future of affordable
spaceflight you know this is just the
start of private space missions because
there are big companies like SpaceX who
will want to continue and launching and
providing launch opportunities and you
know that's what they set up to do
[Music]
successful landings on celestial bodies
are by no means guaranteed Israel will
still be proud of this mission and will
no doubt push to try again Helen Anne
Smith Sky News
[Applause]